what is so powerfully evidence about the
past recipients of this Academy Award is
the strength of the women not just that
of the characters they portray on screen
but in many cases the actresses personal
strength forged in the challenges they
face as women in their real-life journey
to the Oscar stage it's a new day in
Hollywood with new challenges ahead for
all of us but none of us will ever
forget those who came before us
those who blazed a trail for my
generation and for those to come like
Jody who gave me one of my first jobs
when I was 19 and has inspired me every
day and now let's take a look at the
five very inspiring women who are this
year's nominees for best groups
performance by an actress in a leading
role
he didn't even mess up I guess I said
best it wasn't supposed to Sally Hawkins
the shape of water
Frances McDormand three billboards
outside Epping Missouri
[Applause]
margot robbie by time
saoirse ronan ladybird
now Street the post
and the Oscar goes to Frances McDorman
[Applause]
fifth nomination for Frances McDormand
she took home her first Doctor
[Applause]
okay
oh yeah so I'm hyperventilating a little
bit if I fall over pick me up because
I've got some things to say
[Applause]
so I think this is what Chloe Kim must
have felt like after doing back-to-back
1080s in the Olympic halfpipe did you
see that okay that's what it feels like
I want to thank Martin McDonagh look
what you did we are a bunch of hooligans
and anarchists but we do clean up nice
I want to thank every single person in
this building and my sister Dorothy I
love you dot and I especially want to
thank my clan Joel and Pedro Mick Cohen
these two stalwart individuals were well
raised by their feminist mothers they
they value themselves each other and
those around them I know you are proud
of me and that fills me with everlasting
joy and now I want to get some
perspective
if I may be so honored to have all the
female nominees in every category stand
with me in this room tonight the actors
Meryl like you do it everybody else will
come on the filmmaker the producer the
director the writer
the cinematographer
the songwriter
[Applause]
okay look around everybody look around
ladies and gentlemen because we all have
stories to tell and projects we need
finance don't talk to us about it at the
parties tonight Todd invite us into your
office in a couple days or you can come
dars whichever suits you best and we'll
tell you all about them I have two words
to leave with you tonight
ladies and gentlemen inclusion writer
[Applause]